who's really crazy president Trump or
the media that's the focus of tonight's
angle there's been a steady drumbeat
from a bipartisan cabal in the media and
a few in politics who are claiming that
the commander in chief is unfit to serve
not in his right mind insane cuckoo for
cocoa puffs
a New York Times bestselling book by a
group of psychiatrists suggest that the
president is psychologically unstable
and this theory has been gaining
momentum for some months now and I'd say
for a glimpse of true psychological
instability
here's MSNBC's Joe Scarborough from
Morning Joe along with a sampling of
other hysterics you have somebody inside
the White House at the New York Daily
News says is mentally unfit that people
close to him say is mentally unfit that
people close to him during the campaign
told me had early stages of dementia
think about the prospect that the
president United States is is not fully
in his right mind I mean let's just say
it's not it's not fully in touch with
reality and is worsening something is
unleashed with him lately I don't know
what is causing it I don't know how to
describe it
oh you see a different you see a
difference in the past what days we I
think the last couple of days tweets
have been unhinged markedly accelerated
in terms of seeming a little unmoored we
are concerned that the President of the
United States is so unstable is so
volatile has a decision-making process
that is so quixotic that he might order
a nuclear weapons strike that is wildly
out of step with US national security
interests quixotic
big word now consider the people
questioning the president's mental
health fact for instance where did
Scarborough get his psych degree from
talk about delusional and Scarborough is
not the only member of the media
suffering from this severe case of Trump
derangement syndrome but I've got enough
thinking about this I think there my
via method to their madness you see
what's happening is they're deflecting I
think some attention from all the real
basket cases you know their colleagues
in the news rooms with real
psychological issues they're the ones
you've been reading about with careers
going down in flames over habitual
sexual abuse and harassment and yeah
it's kind of a lot easier to talk about
a crazy president who tweets and about
your pals down the hall or maybe the
management upstairs who supposedly knew
nothing about the predatory behavior of
their best friend now you know what the
left I think ultimately is most afraid
of here not that Trump is gonna fail but
that he's actually going to succeed so
they used the word madman to undermine
his credibility while setting up this
narrative to oust him from office D
legitimize the election pull it back now
last night I asked someone who knows a
little bit about the president senator
Majority Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
and I asked him his appraisal of Trump's
mental state those accusations are
absolutely outrageous I managed to speak
to the president of virtually daily
basis and I'm involved with him all the
time on all these issues and that's kind
of accusation is totally baseless and
outrageous I think those kind of
accusations are completely off-base and
irresponsible let's argue over the
issues but the left and a smattering of
defiant never Trump errs they don't want
to talk about the issues and the crazy
talk allows them to divert attention
from all the good the president has done
already for the United States this to
tick off a few of you booming economy
GDP just revised up to three point three
percent stock market we all know hit an
all-time high today of 24,000 Christmas
retail sales up already this season a /
red tape to boost investor confidence
unleashing small businesses across the
United States he's rolled back
regulations that strangled business
growth restoring common sense
conservatism trying to drain the swamp
having some success at moribund
bureaucracies like the state department
and he's nominating a record number of
federal judges and courts across the
land and finally returning fire in the
one sided trade war with China almost
gets no coverage it's that two hundred
fifty billion dollars worth of deals he
brought back after that trip to Asia
he's finally launching a real antique
Jumping case against chinese chinese
aluminum manufacturers and now get this
now he's working with our European
allies to oppose China at the WTO came
out just hours ago their opposing market
economy status for China that's huge
news but where's all the media reporting
and obsessing and all that top Trump aid
Stephen Miller just told the Washington
Examiner if media coverage was fair
unbiased down the middle there'd be a
hundred stories about the unstoppable
momentum and energy of the Oval Office
what's the same thing they did in a way
to my old boss Ronald Reagan they
branded him a doddering old actor while
trying to solve it to sabotage his
agenda and remember these are the same
people who got the election wrong they
said the stock market would tank once
Trump got elected and now they're
desperately trying to revive their own
reputations by defaming the president
and they hope they get what they want in
the end removing him from office that's
what all the crazy talk about and
frankly I think that's crazy and that's
the angle